at this altitude I can my hands this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
man oh man do a lot of listeners of this
podcast and readers of mine love fresh
books to the extent that I ended up
meeting with the CEO not very long ago
why are they so popular well they are
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers a lot
of entrepreneurs and beyond you can take
pictures of receipts you can link your
credit card and debit cards so all the
things you buy automatically appear in
your fresh books in the right category
so on and so forth makes taxes easy
makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put together PDF a while
back called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour workweek with a
service business and the story in that
ebook its PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward-slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
this episode is brought to you by me
undies
I've spent the last few years wearing
underwear from these guys 24/7 or close
to it outside of showers and sexy time
in swimming and they are the most
comfortable and colorful underwear I've
ever owned you should check out the
camouflage boxer briefs I'm a big fan me
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro mowed ow
what's that it is a fabric three times
softer than cotton trust me try it out
you'll understand why I wear these so
much if underwear isn't your thing
though I would imagine everyone wears
underwear but if it isn't your thing my
undies also makes socks their socks are
spun from premium material making them
just as comfortable as the underwear now
right now the undies has an exclusive
offer just for Tim Ferriss show
listeners you can get 20% off your first
order and free shipping so check it out
take a look some of them are pretty rad
they have different cereals from your
childhood on underwear and a lot more me
undies com forward slash Tim take a look
my undies comm forward slash Tim they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you're unhappy with your purchase for
any reason just send them back and you
receive a full refund again that's me
undies comm forward slash Tim for 20%
off and free shipping
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Beres and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where
each episode it is my job to deconstruct
world class performers from all
different spheres of life arenas of
competition this time around it is
entrepreneurship business in just
general awesomeness
we have Arianna Huffington you can find
her on Twitter at Ariana huff and
elsewhere of course on the socials she
has been named to Time magazine's list
of the world's 100 most influential
people and Forbes most powerful women
list originally from Greece she moved to
England when she was 16 and graduated
from Cambridge with an MA in economics
in May 2005 she launched the Huffington
Post a news and blog site that quickly
became one of the most widely read
linked to and frequently cited media
brands on the Internet and in 2012 won a
Pulitzer Prize for national reporting in
August 2016
she launched to thrive global with the
mission of ending the stress and burnout
epidemic by offering companies and
individuals sustainable science-based
solutions to well-being Arianna serves
on a lot of boards including uber and
the Center for Public Integrity and
she's the author of 15 what 15 books
including her most recent thrive
subtitle the third metric to redefining
success in creating a life of well-being
wisdom and Wonder and the sleep
revolution subtitle transforming your
life one night at a time this is a very
wide-ranging conversation we get into
plenty of tactics she is a an expert
storyteller and very very funny to boot
so I hope you enjoy this as much as I
did so without further ado here is my
conversation with Arianna Huffington
Ariana welcome to the show Thank You
team I love your podcast and I'm really
happy to be part of it well I have had
so much fun interacting with you over
the years and also observing you in
environments where you get to ask a lot
of questions so I'm happy to have the
chance to turn the tables and actually
dig into your story because you're
always highlighting people around you
and now it's my chance to turn it around
and dig into a lot of the background
that I haven't heard but I wanted to
start with a question about breakfast
because we did it as a soundcheck I
think people will enjoy it so what did
you have for breakfast this morning so
every morning I have coffee bulletproof
coffee for breakfast which is basically
as you know coffee with organic butter
and then I don't really like breakfast
in terms of food and I was brought up in
Greece and people don't have breakfast
they have coffee and so like a good
Greek peasant girl I don't really eat
until lunchtime and if you want to know
what's my favorite food at lunchtime
it's breakfast so what do you so what do
you have at lunch what is your go-to
lunch right my go-to lunch is poached
eggs or scrambled eggs or boiled eggs
any kind of breakfast food you you have
we're gonna come back to all of your
experimentation because you seem to have
tried just about everything but I want
to give people just a taste perhaps I
mean you've tried firewalking list
making journal keeping infrared saunas
your very game to experiment and I'm
curious to know if there are any
particular practices like those that
have have stuck with you that you've
found continually valuable for you and
it could be part of your daily routine
or it could be some type of object could
be anything
so the part of my daily routine that I
actually started when I was 13 and which
is three thousand years ago and I
I can't say I've done it consistently
every day since but I have in the last
few years done it consistently is
meditating so I I try to do it right
after I wake up before I engage in my
day and and it's been absolutely amazing
in terms of how much peace and strength
and joy it's brought me and as I go
through my day no matter what the
challenges and problems and I've tried
other things which I do intermittently
but not every day like writing down my
dreams mm-hmm there are periods in my
life when I wrote down my dreams every
day and I have like massive notebooks
with my dreams and now I do it
sporadically but I still keep a pen by
my bed that's one of those pens that
light in the night so you don't have to
turn on the light because as you know
and the less intrusion of outside life
you have the more details of your dream
you remember see you have a pen that has
a light on the front of it yes yes I've
never I'm amazed that I've never seen
such a thing
okay I'm sending you one okay I will
I'll definitely try that and I want to
dig into the details of the meditation
and practice for a second what type of
meditation do you practice or what does
a session look like for you so I have
tried every kind of meditation as you as
you kind of already announced you know I
love experimenting so at first when I
was 13 I was believe it or not
initiated into Transcendental Meditation
by Maharishi himself who happen to be
nuthin's Greece Wow and I was this 13
year old girl who this very eccentric
mother who was doing yoga and meditating
and had convinced my sister and me that
if we meditated we would be better at
school and since I was determined to get
great grades I thought this would help
me
that is incredible I had no idea so
you've called your mother a hero before
I've heard this and how we're gonna dig
into some of the lessons that you
learned for from her I'd like to hear
about that but how how did you end up
getting in front of Maharishi and being
inducted in that way how did that come
together
she said she she was kind of amazing she
could make anything happen and I don't
know how she found out where he would be
and how she got her daughter's there but
that's what happened and at the time I
didn't frankly think it was a big deal
I have since also together with my two
daughters who are now 26 and 28 been
reintroduced a Transcendental Meditation
by Bob Roth who is a fabulous teacher
here in New York but also in the
meantime I have practiced many other
kinds of many other kinds of meditation
you know Buddhist meditation compassion
meditation and also meditation am taught
by John Raja
you know who started the movement for
spiritual inner awareness so I am i
basically meditate with a tone but
focusing very much on my breath you know
the the inhalation and exhalation is
just a big part of my meditation and on
an everyday basis I do half an hour but
offer the weekend or wherever I can I
made one
they did two hours and the other thing
that is great team we said if I wake up
in the middle of the night for whatever
reason and I have trouble going back to
sleep let's say I'm particularly
stressed overthinking something I'm on a
plane I'm jet-lagged whatever I just
never worry about it anymore I just say
this is amazing I have unlimited time to
meditate right you were you're gifted
the plane delay or whatever it might be
when it happens it's like 3:00 in the
morning or which is according to the
Dalai Lama the optimal time to meditate
it's very clear you know all the new
science on sleep shows that something
which an experiment which they call
paradoxical intention that if you take
two groups of people and you tell one
group to try and go back to sleep and
another group to stay awake the group
that you to whom you said stay awake
falls asleep faster that's funny right
it's like it's one of those things where
the key is to try less surrender and
trying to surrender is really hard it is
hard I think it's expression especially
hard for type-a personalities but you
mentioned that your mother could make
anything happen and you also mentioned
that you were seemed at least driven to
get very good grades where did that were
did that desire to get good grades come
from I don't really know where that came
from but I I was a very sort of awkward
kid I was ridiculously tall for a Greek
girl I was literally 5 feet 10 when I
was 13 years old and that most of my
classmates were 5 feet nothing
I was literally towering all over the
house in a girl school
and just to give you an idea of how bad
that was I was excluded from the school
parade where they had you know the
tallest girls because I was too tall and
I would stick out too much so I also had
very frizzy hair and wore glasses and so
I just really spent a lot of time just
reading and studying rather than having
a lot of friends and being Sascha which
is okay well we're gonna bounce around
on the timeline a bit so that's just how
my mind works I'm surprised to hear that
because you are one of the most if not
the most socially adept person I've ever
seen in life I mean it's really like
watching you know Tom Brady playing
football or something to watch you
navigate and manage your room I'm not
kidding it's really impressive I mean
when I've been at say dinners with you
just observing how you weave everyone
together is as enjoyable to me as the
conversations that I have so how did you
learn to be social well Tim it's kind of
interesting because I know it's hard to
believe but I'm I am an introvert and
the reason I know that is that I have
experienced every emotion in my life
including rage and fear and
disappointment and everything you can
imagine but I have never experienced
loneliness I need time alone and I long
for time alone and I've never said that
this is too much time alone so I think
that's a pretty good indication that I'm
fundamentally an introvert who loves
people and provided I have enough time
to refuel by myself and if I do then I
love I love bringing people together I
think that's one of the things I'm most
loved is kind of introducing my friends
to each other
making sure they are connecting setting
people up numerous ways to really make
sure that people I care about are
connected to each other okay so I want
to putting the pieces together slowly
and kind of like the movie memento if
anybody gets that but what took you I
know that we're we're jumping around but
I'm sort of following the scent as we go
what led you to move to the UK so again
that's another mother story because I
saw in a magazine a picture of Cambridge
University and I absolutely fell in love
with it I have no idea why and I said to
my mother with absolute conviction I
want to go there and everybody else I
said that to my dad my friends said
don't be ridiculous you can't go there
how old were you at the time I was 14
okay got it and they all said you have
no you don't speak English and we have
no money and it's hard even for English
girls to get into Cambridge so forget
about that and my mother said okay let's
find out how you can get to Cambridge
I'm sure we can make that happen and so
she found out that I could take my what
they call GC is general certificates of
Education which you needed together and
if you still do to get into English
universities from the British Council
but then I would have to take a special
Cambridge exam that I could apply for a
scholarship and of course I immediately
started learning English and up until
then I had learned French because in in
Greece French was the official language
the time the official foreign language
so I had learned French at school
immediately started learning English and
to cut the long story short I got a
scholarship into Cambridge and
definitely that would never have
happened without my mother saying let's
make that happen she even said to me one
day you know I got us these really cheap
tickets and we can go and see Cambridge
not see anybody at Cambridge just go see
it it was like an early form of
visualization so she and I she and I
usually flew to London took a train to
Cambridge and just walked around and
made it real for me and that was her
that was how she was and she pursued let
me just make sure I understand this she
took you to Cambridge so you could walk
around Cambridge feeling like you're
already part of it is that exactly
Wow I did do you find that helpful for
you I did it just made it very really
took it from a magazine picture to a
real place where we walked around for
hours and saw the different colleges and
had coffee in the coffee shop and saw
the river and and of course by the end
of it I wanted to go to Cambridge more
than ever
hmm is are there any particular
parenting approaches or sayings that you
use with your daughters that your mother
used with you has it has her parenting
style influenced how you parent
completely my parenting style is
identical except I'm I'm perpetually
guilty because I'm definitely not as
good as she laughs you know in any case
I think most mothers are guilty about
something especially working mothers
they say you take the baby out and they
put a guillotine but for me I think the
heart of it
is unconditional loving that was really
her biggest gift to love you
unconditionally while at the same time
making you believe that you could do
anything you wanted to try but that if
you failed not a problem because as she
used to say that was one of her favorite
things failure is not the opposite of
success it's a stepping stone to success
so she made my sister and me feel very
comfortable with failing it was not a
big deal
taking risks was part of life and and
failing was part of life and and then
she was very funny
and she used to say Angels fly because
they take themselves seriously and and
whatever happened bad things happening
she just little bad things were bad bad
things bad bad things like my father
being a philanderer and her ending
ending up separating from him they never
actually got divorced and how she turned
that around and still managed to create
an amazingly warm loving home for us or
little things like our favorite thing
for our birthdays was to go with her to
two movies in a play and so we're ready
to leave our apartment with my sister
and we locked our keys in so every other
mother would have just kind of dropped
the program and tried to forget the keys
etc my mother said okay no problem let's
just go to the movies and go to the play
let's keep to our schedule and we'll
figure it out and of course by the time
we were opposite the fire station so
when we got back she went to the fire
station and asked if they could help us
and because she was always such a giver
she would always bring everybody food
and help them with anything they wanted
the firefighters put up a ladder up and
in through the window so it seems like
I'd be just by watching your mother and
experiencing that that over time you
would you would feel like you could
figure out just about anything I mean
just seeing someone being that adaptable
I would think would would really impact
you I mean the question that I've been
wanting to ask also about a few of these
things you mentioned the failure as a
stepping stone and so on you talked
about not speak English when you saw
this picture of Cambridge in a magazine
but I read that you became really
determined to excel in the debate
Society at Cambridge I don't know if
that's accurate or not but if it is can
you can you walk us through your
decision to do that and what you were
thinking at the time because I would
imagine that would be very intimidating
yes so actually what happened is that I
was absolutely fascinated by debates at
Cambridge I love them more than anything
at Cambridge and I was determined to
learn to speak you know to learn to
speak publicly and so I would literally
and stay at every debate until the
bitter end and I would wait my turn to
be called on to speak because they would
have the main speakers and then anybody
could could speak but I was terrible and
I had a very heavy accent even heavier
than now and so I was normally picked
last like kind of midnight but it didn't
matter just sat there I made notes I
learned and but I hadn't really thought
of competing to to be elected to an
office at the Union that seemed like not
something I could ever achieve so what
happened is that one weekend when I was
in London a friend of mine put me down
for the election to
Standing Committee which was like the
first step before you became a secretary
and a vice president a new president and
I was deeply embarrassed when I found
that out I thought I would be humiliated
and I tried to get my name off it when
it was too late the ballot said we bring
it and then to my immense surprise
i I I was elected to the top of the
Standing Committee which was a complete
surprise
I would really never ever ever have
guessed that this would happen but
that's how I ended up you know then
being elected secretary and vice vice
president and then president so the
decision to learn to speak was very very
deliberate the the father ended up
becoming president of the union which
culturally was a defining moment in
terms of my career was completely
accidental
and dependent on on this friend of mine
who took matters in her own hands why
was it a defining moment for you
why do you it's hard to to understand
how much at the time it meant to be
elected president of the Union there was
this kind of mythical place that the
Oxford and Cambridge unions have in in
the history of England you know that's a
big deal I visited campus once and
walked through the hallways it's a very
very big deal and you were the I guess
the first foreign and only the third
female yes yes and and so what happened
is that when I was elected it was it was
like front front page news it's hard to
it's hard to believe it but like The
Times The Guardian they had front-page
pictures of me on them
this is thrown at the president seats on
and and I was invited to do every show
you can imagine and and that's when in
the course of one of the debates that I
was
speaking out as president and which was
televised because a lot of the debates
were televised a publisher I saw the
debate and asked me to write a book
based on the views expressed in the
debate so it truly was defining because
I had no intention of being a writer
sounds like everything that happened to
me was not intended but so I I got this
letter from reg Davies point it would
just actually publish the main Greer's
book the Female Eunuch and he asked me
if I would write a book expressing the
views that I had expressed in them in
the debate and I wrote back and I said I
can't write and he said can you have
lunch and he took me to lunch and
offered me a modest advance and he said
if you if he turns out you can't write
I'll have lost nothing it was six
thousand pounds for a year so and
otherwise he said I will publish the
book and that was my first book it
changed the trajectory of my career
because I had just gotten into the candy
school of government to do a
postgraduate degree there which I am I
dropped in order to to write the book
what was what was that first book what
was the title the title was the female
woman and the message of the book well
it was really very matter-of-fact now
because it was the fact my belief that
women should be given equal respect for
whatever they choose to do in their
lives if they choose to have a career
everything should be open to them if
they choose to be mothers and they can
afford to do so and not have a career
there should be given equal respect for
that now that now seems like no big deal
at the time it was very controversial
because it was at the it was published
in 1970
three I was 23 years old and at the time
it was at the moment at the height of
what was known as the women's liberation
movement when only career women we're
respected you know if you chose and
you're able to financially not to have a
career you're kind of dismissed as
having succumbed to social conditioning
or the patriarchy and and I interviewed
a lot of women who made a lot of
difficult choices like they designed I
remember a woman saying I haven't had a
new coat for three years but I want to
bring up my children myself and then I
can get back into the workplace so I
wasn't saying that one choice was better
than another but that part of equality
was equal respect for whatever choices
women made you you've had so many
opportunities to interact with so many
people who you could potentially guide
or mentor and just given that were
somewhat on the subject I mean if you
were looking at one piece of that
equation so you're looking at the
professional choice going into the
business world is is the advice you
would give a young man or a young woman
the same or is there different advice
that you would give to young women who
are considering really focusing on
charging headfirst into the business
world oh absolutely and the same advice
the only thing that's different for
women if they want to have children is
to be aware of that I mean now of course
women can freeze the rags so it gives
them a longer timeline for becoming
mothers or they can choose to adopt so
that's great because it gives women more
flexibility
but I think the most important thing is
to to really be honest with yourself I
mean I would not have been happy if I
had not had my work I knew that was very
important to me and I actually have
never not worked and also would not have
been happy if I had not had children but
I have many friends of mine who don't
want children and they are perfectly
happy so I that's why I'm saying this is
very individual and all that matters is
to be ruthlessly honest with ourselves
and and basically making sure that the
life we're following is the life we are
choosing for ourselves rather than the
life that has been chosen for us by
society or parents or friends yeah now
you have told us about one defining
moment which was this this appointment I
guess on the throne and everything that
came out of that if we then look forward
after that what would you consider the
next sort of defining moment or defining
decision in your life or the next that
comes to mind for you oh I could say the
next defining decision was deciding to
leave this man that I was very much in
love with because he didn't want to have
children and by then I was 30 I had been
with him since I was 23 for seven years
he was twice my age and half my size
[Laughter]
he was an amazing writer his name was
Bernard Levin and he was a great
columnist for the London Times and also
very much a writing mentor to me
and but he kept saying I don't know one
with kids I only wanted with cats and
and he was perfectly happy to be with me
for the rest of his life but without
children and I was very clear that I
wanted to have children so I made the
decision to leave him and because I
didn't trust myself not to go back to
him if I had stayed in London I left
London and moved to New York so
everything that happened to me after
that my the rest of my work launching
the Huffington Post having my two
daughters all of a team happened because
a man wouldn't marry me and have
children with me so well it's kind of
like if you have insomnia at 3:00 in the
morning right maybe maybe it's sort of a
horror a hard moment an opportunity or a
gift disguised as a very hard moment and
for those people who don't know how did
the Huffington Post come to be so you
land in New York how how did the
Huffington Post come to be oh that's the
Huffington Post is many many years after
I land in New York so I was born in 1950
so I'm 67 I left London in 1980 when I
was 30 and moved to New York and then
continued writing you know written 15
books and after the book that we
discussed the female woman I wrote a
book on political leadership called
after reason which nobody wanted to buy
but that's another story and then I
wrote biographies of Maria Callas and
later Pablo Picasso so when I came to
New York I had just published my
biography of Maria Callas with an opera
singer best known among people who don't
love opera as the woman who was
very much in love with aristotle onassis
but Onassis left her to marry Jackie
Kennedy just to put it in context and so
when I came to New York my book on Maria
Callas had just been published and so I
was which made it easier to move to New
York because I was I was here
publicizing my book the book turned out
to be a big bestseller and and it led to
my doing journalism and writing more
books why by now moving and living in
New York
how 15 books is a lot of books what is
your writing process or what helps you
to be so prolific I'm always impressed
and have been impressed when I've
considered how many books you've written
what what helps you to achieve that type
of volume so my writing process changed
dramatically at the beginning my writing
process was painstaking and incredibly
slow because I had this sort of inner
censor so I would write a sentence and
then the inner censor would step in and
say that's not the right word and I
would spend a long time arguing with
myself about what the right word was and
gradually I realized that I was able to
speak without notes for an hour longer
and that I should use that skill to
create first drafts so I started
dictating my first draft ideally to
somebody I work with because I like
having that kind of response from
someone if you're in the same room and
you are speaking and they are typing
but you kind of they smile or the guffaw
or they they show whether they liked or
didn't like something and and that has
dramatically accelerated my writing
process because it's so much easier as
you know team to edit a first draft and
edit it extensively and go through
multiple editing editing processes than
it is to write a first draft and is the
is the person you're speaking to
interacting with you are asking you
questions or are they just listening and
transcribing they're perfectly free to
interrupt and say anything but largely
it's just listening but just kind of you
know how people listen but they they
show you if they get if they agree or if
they like something or if they didn't
get it it's like it's it's very subtle
but obvious oh for sure I mean you can
see that's that's one thing I always pay
attention to when I have proofreaders
reading my material I like to be there
when they read it because if they laugh
I always say okay what was that and
they'll say oh noes nothing and I'm like
no no what was it what made you laugh I
always want to know what provokes the
response no I asked about the the
interaction because I remember with the
4-hour workweek in particular I hit a
point where I was really stuck and I was
stuck not for a day but for about two
weeks and I didn't know how to tackle
this chapter so I decided to we I had
the intention of having someone
interview me so they could ghost write a
first draft that I could then use as a
jumping-off point but I've I learned as
they interviewed me over the course of
about 90 minutes that they had actually
helped me figure out how to fix the
chapter just by interviewing me because
I was too close to the material so I'm
really fascinated by using those types
of tools to jumpstart or like you said
to get a first draft out because that is
so difficult at times
that's where I'm glad to hear that you
you have a kind of similar process
yeah the interviewing I find is a great
way to take a step back from the
material I never give if I need someone
to interview me to figure out a given
chapter or aspect of a book I I never
give them any background because I want
them to come in fresh like a reader who
just picked it up off the shelf without
any type of any type of context so the
you're writing in working on all these
books when was the decision made to turn
the Huffington Post into a company or to
create that company so by 2000 I started
seeing that a lot of very rich
conversation was moving online and that
a lot of the people I loved and admired
were not going to be part of it because
they were never going to start a blog
and because at the time you know
bloggers were seen as people who
couldn't get a job and were blogging
remember the cliche from their parents
basement right right and so I started
writing in my column I had a column a
syndicated column at the time about
bloggers and and I just really loved
this what blogging was which was being
more conversational being more intimate
responding to your readers they respond
back the whole interactive nature so I
am decided together with my co-founder
Kenny lair to launch the Huffington Post
in 2005 and as as two things one was a
collection of bloggers and commenting on
anything from the events of the day to
food to movies anything at all I mean
one of our saying
if you have something to say say it on
the Huffington Post and also a
journalistic Enterprise where we
practiced conventional journalism
investigative journalism at the
beginning the blogging part was the
dominant part until we started raising
and making money to be able to hire
journalists and the first day we
launched was kind of a new day for
blogging because suddenly we had we had
on our front page and people like Nora
Ephron and Walter Cronkite and John
Cusack and Larry David and people were
never blogged before and it began the
process of elevating blogging to
something that of course now we all do
there's no journalist to reason blogging
at the same time and and gradually we
started adding journalists who ended up
winning a Pulitzer for Investigative
Journalism and from the beginning I saw
half Post as a combination of the best
of the old and the best of the new how
did you get all those known names to
participate during the launch what did
you what did you say to them or how did
you convince how did you convince them
to do that so what kind of people I had
met and I wrote to them and basically my
pitch was you wake up in the morning and
you have something to say I know you do
about the events of the day about a
movie you saw last night about anything
and but you're busy you have a book to
write you have a company to run and you
know sure you could write it for the New
York Times but you have to deal with
editors and processors and you don't
really bother just send it to us and put
it in an email and send it to me and
we'll publish it exactly as you sent it
to us and you'll have entered the
cultural
blood stream you'll have entered the
conversation and you don't have to do
anything else and people can comment
react take it to the next level and it
was amazing that's exactly what happened
I remember I remember when the day that
it was revealed who deep throat was I
don't know if you remember that Timor
she was still in kindergarten I should
say I'm aware of it but I don't want to
say I remember it because maybe I wasn't
kindergarten but I'm not sure actually
in 2005 yeah there we go then I was a
few years after kindergarten so and Nora
Ephron called me and said listen
everybody wants me to comment on that
the New York Times asked me to write
about it CNN wants me to go speak about
it because she was at the time married
to Carl Bernstein and so everybody
wanted to know did she know what did she
think etc but she said you know what I'm
instead going to write it for the
Huffington Post and she did it was a big
moment for us why did she choose to do
that
she and I were friends she believed in
what I was doing and and she was Nora
Ephron and she wanted to try new things
and as she said I don't want to put
makeup on and go to CNN I'm writing
another book and I don't want to spend
time arguing with New York Times editors
about a sentence I want to spend 20
minutes write this down and you publish
it and but what was amazing team was
what happened afterwards because Nora
Ephron's piece was everywhere it was in
the New York Times and it was on CNN and
suddenly people began to realize that it
no longer mattered where you wrote
something if it was interesting or
newsworthy or important in some way or
another it would be everywhere so I want
you
I'm gonna pick that up in a second but
you see as you were recalling the rough
pitch that you gave to these people and
you mentioned entering the cultural
bloodstream so I've seen you in action
talking to people brainstorming ideas
suggesting ideas and you're you're very
very good at pitching and persuading
where did you pick that up
is that from debate or is it from
something else are there other ways that
you develop that skill because you're
very good at it I think for me
persuasion is about seeing what does the
other person want and I mean remember
you and I were at the dinner a month ago
and there was a famous designer there we
will not mention his name and as you
know I believe that it's great if people
were dedicated sleep well when they go
to sleep unless they like to sleep naked
because it's kind of rekindles their
amounts with sleep and it makes it clear
to their brains that they're going to
sleep so I thought it would be great to
get a big designer designing not just
clothes but sleep well but he had
already told me that he liked breaking
rules and doing things differently and
so for me when I preached the idea of
designing sleepwear I knew what the
opening was that he that he liked to
break conventions and do things
differently and that he was asking his
team to do the same so it turned out to
be a really fun conversation and we are
talking about him designing sleepwear
but for me the key is to find out what
is the common point of what I'd like to
see happen and what the other person
would like to see happen so if you if
you a mean you have a very good
portfolio of skills for many of the
things that you've ended up building and
if you were for instance teaching a what
you can choose the
let's just call it either freshman year
in college or senior year in college
you're teaching a seminar and it's a
small group of students let's call it 20
students and you're trying to get them
ready for professional life or business
life what would you focus on teaching
them in this seminar let's just say it's
once per week you have two to three
hours with them for us for a single
semester what would you what would you
teach what would you focus on oh right
now I would absolutely focus on them
prioritizing their own human capital a
lot of people think that success is
about what we get from the outside but
the truth is that success is so based on
what we can create from what we have
inside us and how we can access that
place of creativity and resilience and
peace inside us I'm so convinced of that
now and and it's getting harder and
harder because the distractions the
invasiveness of technology are so
overwhelming so I don't think there is
anything more important and it helps you
come up with the best ideas it helps you
not burnout which makes you more
resilient in terms of facing noes and
failure so that would definitely be my
seminar in what what tools or
suggestions or practices would you try
to impart to these students because
let's just say if we're talking about
Cambridge they've they've almost
pre-qualified already as type-a
personalities probably right I mean
these are very ambitious kids so what
would you are there any particular tools
or philosophies or books or anything
that you would recommend to them to arm
them way for defending against burnout
later
yes I I would recommend that they read
the latest science around the importance
of sleep and pauses in the course of our
day because we claim to be data-driven
but in fact we are living our lives
ignoring the data the preb the
prevailing culture still believes that
being always on is the way to succeed
that cutting down on sleep means we are
more productive because because we have
more time available so I would show them
the latest science and then I would
bring together new role models people in
the arena that they admire and if they
admire business people people like Jeff
Bezos who wrote on thrive global why he
gets eight hours of sleep a night as he
put it it's good for Amazon shareholders
because and he broke it down he said
when I get six hours my decision-making
is 5 to 20% less good than when I've had
eight hours and my value is entirely
dependent on the quality of my decisions
now that's entirely based on science and
on his personal observation of how he
makes decisions or if people are more
likely to be swayed by cultural icons I
would quote Selena Gomez who wrote for
us why she does a regular digital detox
because as she put it when she does a
digital detox she reconnects with
herself and is much more present in
everything she's doing in her life what
does the digital detox look like for her
or for anyone else you might want to try
it well people can pick their own way of
doing it but it's basically taking it
could be anything from a day and we can
an hour
from their phones dick not Han said it's
never easier to run away from ourselves
the human attention span is now shorter
than the shoe then the attention span of
the goldfish it's down to eight seconds
so anything we can do
that helps us disconnect from the
distractions reconnect with ourselves
whatever form it takes I'm a big
believer in micro steps like if the idea
of one day digital detox is overwhelming
just trying out try half an hour
whatever and whatever your entry point
is just take it
so what out that I'll mention a few may
be micro steps that I've found helpful
for myself then I'd love to hear some of
yours because I've noticed for myself at
least that I always put my phone on
airplane mode after typically after
dinner and it stays in airplane mode
until I've meditated the next morning
that is one practice and I've been doing
that for probably two years now because
I've noticed that if if I do not have it
on airplane mode number one there will
be lights and so on in my bedroom which
is not ideal and I know that you have
quite a bit to say on that and I also
find that if if I am barrage by any type
of inputs in the morning before doing my
meditation the meditation is of a very
very low quality and the second thing
that I do on a weekly basis is I try to
take what I would call what I do call
screen free Saturdays and it doesn't
mean that I'm totally avoiding
electronics because I will I don't own a
car currently and I'll use my phone for
say uber Google Maps and so on but
otherwise I'm not using a laptop and I'm
not using social media of any type so on
Saturdays that is a weekly sort of
Sabbath away from a lot of the
distractions are there any other micros
that you might recommend to people or
that you found personally helpful that's
fantastic and I know how many people
have been influenced by you doing that
for me another little micro step is not
charging our phone by our bed and the
reason for that is that we are all
slightly addicted to our phones and even
with the best intentions if we wake up
in the middle of the night and we can't
easily go back to sleep and our phone is
right by our bed we are going to be
tempted to pick up the phone and and
look at our texts or look at Instagram
and that will dramatically interfere
with our ability to go back to sleep and
truly recharge so that's one little
micro step another micro step for me
which is similar to yours is never
rushing to my phone at the beginning of
the of the morning the first thing I do
but have my own ritual which includes
meditation and which includes setting my
intention for the day before I get on my
phone and when I get on I love doing my
stationary bike in the morning I'm
perfectly fine being on my phone and
answering emails while on the bike what
is a black sheep I'm going to ask you
about your morning routine and then I'm
gonna come back to why all this became
so important to you but what is your
morning look like do you have any
particular routines that could you walk
us through the first say 90 minutes of
your day when you wake up and then what
happens after that so first of all I I
just want to say that I I don't believe
in having the same time to go to sleep
at night and the same time to wake up in
the morning kind of my life doesn't work
like that and I
like setting up rules which I'm going to
break every day so I'm my goal now is to
wake up eight hours after I went to
sleep right because I have found out
that eight hours is what I need to
operate on optimally and also it happens
to be what a lot of people need you know
the scientists have told us that unless
you have a genetic mutation in which
case you can do great on three or four
hours and about one and a half percent
of the population has that the rest of
us need seven to nine hours to to have a
fully restorative sleep so that's kind
of my my ground rule to myself and and
95% of the time I do it I'm I don't do
anything perfectly and I'm a work in
progress but I think 95 percent is
pretty good so you wake up eight hours
let's say after you've gone to bed and
then what happens after that and then I
am the first thing I do is sort of
meditate and set and then after my
meditation I set my intention for the
day like what what what is what do I
want out of the day in terms of my work
or my being or my family and the reason
why I think it's so important is because
I used to just go straight to my phone
or my laptop and that's what the world
wants of us right it's every email in
every text and and I feel it's very
important for us to be clear about what
we want because you can't really run
your life from your inbox no well as a
friend of mine put it who he put this to
me and he learned it from someone else
who's billionaire who said to him you
know that your inbox is everyone else's
agenda for your time
I love that and that's a very good way
to think about it because it's extremely
reactive and you seem to have very
proactive programming in a way and you
do seem to have certain routines or
rituals I'd love to talk about and this
this will tie into a lot of what we're
talking about walking could you -
because I've read in doing research for
our conversation that one of your
favorite phrases and I'm gonna mess this
up because this looks like Latin is sofa
to ramble on though it which means it is
solved by walking could you please talk
about walking and what role it has in
your life so you know I lived in Los
Angeles for many years I and my two
daughters went to school there and I
lived in Brentwood and it's kind of
amazing that there are hikes everywhere
literally five minutes in the car from
my home they're the most beautiful hikes
the Mandeville Canyon KY hike and the
canter hike and so I got into the habit
of having all my meetings quorum court
lunches etc with friends during hike so
instead of going for a lunch or a
meeting with friends we would go on a
hike and the one was in better shape
would talk on the way up and the one was
in worse shape would talk on the way
down and some of the best things
happened on these hikes I remember
telling all my girlfriend's about my
idea of launching the Huffington Post
and Lori David what the time was married
to Larry David immediately said I'll
invest in fact Lori and Larry invested
together and then when they got divorced
they split the investments
and and Kimberly Brooks became my first
art editor and it was just like a great
way to just talk about everything
whether it was work or personal life and
there was something about being in
nature that made us all more willing to
be authentic and vulnerable and still
now when I get to LA I I see my friends
on hikes or walks around the block or
whatever we have time for but I love it
and of course now being in New York it's
fantastic because I can walk everywhere
it's a great walking City New York is
really a fantastic walking City and I've
I've noticed a number of my what I would
consider most productive friends which
is saying a lot a lot of productive
friends but for instance navall rava
khan who's really a very soulful and
intelligent person who's been on this
podcast before does walk and talk
meetings so he'll have someone come and
meet him this is in San Francisco and it
might just be a walk around several
blocks and doing a few laps of that
route but he will do walk and talk in
that way and I've also noticed that a
few of my friends who I would also put
in that top performing category they'll
do walk in talks but they'll do it with
video FaceTime so that they can look at
the other person as they're walking
which is quite clever
well actually walking meetings is
another great thing to do and we do a
lot of it here and I thrive especially
if it's one on one it gets hard
navigating the streets of New York it's
more than two people you can do it up to
three and then it gets really hard what
what if you don't mind and this will
perhaps lead us into thrive but what
we're could you talk about one of the
hard
or darker periods during the the huffing
Huffington Post years and what helped
you to get out of it and just walk us
through maybe a story of one of those
times because I think that it's very
easy for people listening to this
podcast to put the people being
interviewed on a pedestal and assume
they've always had everything figured
out and they just step up to the plate
and always hit home runs but is there
any particular tough period or time at
huffington post that you could tell us
about and what helped you to get through
it or get out of it yes absolutely and
I'm so glad you're focusing on that
because the worst thing we can do is
give people the delusion that everything
has been plain sailing for me the
hardest time was two years into building
half Post when I was literally working
around the clock I also had two
daughters who at the time were teenagers
and that's probably the hardest time for
a mother and her teenage daughters and I
was divorced so I was bringing them up
on my own and my oldest daughter was at
the time when we did the college tools
to decide what college she was going to
go and basically what would happen she
had made that rule which was very
legitimate no BlackBerry's it was
blackberry time and when we were
together so she and I would be together
going from college to college during the
day and at night we would check into a
hotel she would go to sleep and I would
start working so I got back to Los
Angeles and I was completely exhausted
without even realizing I was completely
exhausted and running on empty until I
got up from my desk that first morning
back because I was feeling cold to get a
sweater and I collapsed and hit my head
on my desk broke my cheekbone
got first teachers on my right eye and
that was the the beginning of the
journey that led to the Thrive book and
the sleep revolution book and the Thrive
company at the time it was a very dark
time because first of all when something
like that happens
nobody knows what's wrong with you do
you have a brain tumor do you have a
heart problem so it was literally two
weeks of going from Doctor to doctor
from MRI to electrocardiogram to check
what was wrong with me and at the end of
this two weeks I feel this was a movie I
would have had all the doctors in one
room in their white coats basically give
me the diagnosis which is arianah you
are suffering from civilizations disease
burnout and there is nothing we can do
for you you have to change your life and
and it really took that painful wake-up
call for me to realize that I had to
change my life and that's why now I'm I
feel such an evangelist about this topic
because I feel people can make
incremental changes in their lives
before they hit the proverbial wall and
what is funny to him is that if you had
to ask me that morning ariana Hawaii
would have said fine because I had
forgotten what being fine really was
[Music]
being like perpetually tired had become
the new normal and and I had literally
forgotten it so much so that I wasn't
even aware of the fact that I was
running on empty so I'm really glad
we're talking about this and I just want
to reflect on one thing you said which
is
how you would have said you were fine
because you'd forgotten what normal
actually was I remember a few years ago
I hit a point of burnout complete
burnout
right after during and then right after
the 4-hour chef for many reasons but I
won't bore everybody right now and what
I ended up doing after that as as part
of my attempt to recover was agreeing to
do my first meditation retreat of it was
only two or three days and there are a
number of rules rule number one was you
can't use an alarm clock and if you need
to sleep and that's all you do this
weekend then that's what you do and I
felt like that was going to be a huge
waste because I knew I was tired but
that was part 1 and part 2 was they
recommended that everyone cut back on
caffeine intake which is my I suppose
one of my compounds of choice
fortunately I'm not drawn to opiates but
stimulants are unfortunately something
that has have often been right at my
side and my body just seems to to crave
and respond to that with a certain
degree of addiction so I had been in my
normal routine for months prior to that
going to a Thai restaurant that would
let me sit down and work on my book and
they would give me the unending cup or
glass of iced tea so it ended up
drinking two or three gallons probably
of iced tea and that and that was my
normal right so that's just what I
assumed
baseline felt like and then for the
first time in probably six months I went
completely off of caffeine in
preparation for this retreat proceeded
to sleep almost the entire weekend and
felt rejuvenated no gadgets or devices
then I went back to in this case San
Francisco where I used to live and what
did I do I went back into my routine and
I went to the Thai restaurant and then I
remember after maybe two or three
glasses of iced tea and keeping in mind
before that
I was drinking twenty thirty not feeling
anything that was just status quo and I
had maybe three glasses and I felt so
agitated and so unpleasant that I
realized oh my god like this times ten
was what I assumed was normal just a
week or two ago and it was just
mind-boggling I mean it was it was such
a wake-up call for me but I feel like
I'm I'm giving a confessional I just
wanted to share it but what were some of
the first things that you did after you
hit your head saw these doctors they say
you need to change your life in the say
week that followed what did you do well
first of all I love your story because
it's the same message that we we both
want to impart which is how often we're
not even aware of what we are doing to
ourselves and that's why by listening to
each other stories we can increase our
own awareness so for me that first of
all this first two weeks were spent
going to doctors and asking questions
and you know I've always been drawn to
philosophy
I've always loved reading the Greeks and
the Romans and everyone in between and
the one question that really every
philosopher asks is what is a good life
and I feel that what we've done is we've
reduced the answer to that question to
what is a very success and we've reduced
the good life to a successful life and
we've reduced success down to money and
power as large status so kind of
shrunken the definition of a good life
and and I found that during that time I
went back to books I loved and had read
before so it's not as if this was like a
new journey for me I had always been
drawn to that quest
but this was something that had a new
urgency and a new determination to
actually live differently and not just
read great books and were there any
particular changes you were there any
particular books you remember having a
renewed impact on you and then were
there any particular steps that you took
after that yes actually a book that I
read that I had not read before and
which was recommended by a friend was
incredibly powerful for me because it
was written by a man who was in the
arena and yet lived life the way I
wanted to live my life and that was
Marcus Aurelius yes meditations
meditations that was a pretty big job he
had faced invasions and plagues and
betrayals and an unfaithful wife and yet
he was able to be imperturbable that was
my favorite word at the time and and be
very connected to that centered place in
himself from which he wrote this amazing
book called meditations and I love that
because you know it's easy to read books
by Buddhist monks Christian mystics and
and you want I wanted to hear from
somebody who was in the arena right
someone who was on the front lines
actually having to deal with the
difficulties and messiness of the real
world yes and and I don't I'm not
suggesting that my life was anything
like mark was a religious life but
nevertheless I was in the arena I I I
had to deal with the daily challenges of
life and work and
and there was one quote in fact which I
have laminated and carry with me that I
love so much in the book and it goes as
follows people look for retreats for
themselves in the country by the coast
or in the hills there is nowhere that a
person can find a more peaceful and
trouble-free retreat than in his own
mind so constantly give yourself this
retreat and renew yourself that is a
great quote that is a really really
really great quote yeah I don't think
I'm amazed we haven't talked about this
we're only talking about Marcus Aurelius
and I'm not going to go off on a crazy
stoic I also have a quote from
meditations and I tend to be a sin ACOG
eye which is its is controversial but
he's a beautiful writer and and people
very often when they are if they get
bitten by the bug of stoic philosophy
tend to go say to Marcus Aurelius or
Seneca often like both and then there's
a say maybe 10% who love Epictetus for
any number of reasons but there's
there's this quote from and I I don't
recall it exactly because it's actually
on my refrigerator and I'm not near my
refrigerator but in in effect it says
when you are taken away from the harmony
you know do what you can to return to it
as easily as possible or as effortlessly
as possible and it is its suppose of a
reminder to me that it's it's not so
much the goal to never be off balance
it's to regain your balance I love that
I couldn't agree more in fact it is
impossible to always be in that centered
place there is no human being on earth
that I have ever met maybe there is some
enlightened saint somewhere who can be
in that center place all the time so
you're absolutely right it's all about
how quickly can we cause
recked now you mentioned the arena and
you have certainly been in the arena in
many different ways in in in your
lifetime so far and a no doubt you will
continue to be in the area NEX I think
you enjoy the full contact sport of it I
wanted to ask you a question about
hiring at thrive and this what I'm about
to read comes from a piece in ink
magazine and I just love to hear you
either fact check it and just correct it
or elaborate on it because of course
quotes are not always accurate on the
internet but sometimes they are so what
it says is now during interviews there's
a speech I give to everybody and this is
quoting you and the speech is something
like this for potential new hires I give
you full permission to walk into my
office and scream at me but I want you
to consider this as my last warning
if you complain about any of your
colleagues behind their backs
you'd be let go it does make and then
you go on to comment on how it makes a
difference when you tell people this I
had never known this but can you can you
tell us more about whether if this is
accurate and then what the speech is and
why you give it so I really believe that
we are moving away from what is seen as
traditional HR practice which is you can
complain to HR about a colleague HR goes
to the colleague and says somebody not
naming who complained about them and and
it becomes this like kind of games
shrouded in secrecy that creates a very
toxic environment and I believe where HR
is moving to now and certainly this is
what we both practice and teach in the
work we are doing corporations is
authentic transparency and I believe
that people who trust themselves and
trust it
they are willing to have difficult
conversations you know relationships are
not easy whether they're work
relationships or personal relationships
we may upset each other we may say
something the other person takes the
wrong way you may do something that
upsets someone I give everybody complete
permission started with me to come and
tell me directly that I did something
that didn't like I said something in
like and when I say scream I I want to
make the point that say it in as royal
way as you want you don't have to figure
it out how to say it you don't have to
you can say it while you are angry don't
you don't have to wait to count down
whatever but if you're incapable of
doing that if you are only capable of
passive-aggressive behavior which is
always being nice to your managers or to
your colleagues while bad-mouthing them
behind their backs consider this your
last warning I mean if we say that as
clearly as we have said it and not I
just I but everybody here but you are
but you can't do it then this is not the
right place for you I love that I wish
more people did this because I feel like
and I don't want to I'm trying to hold
myself back I've had too much caffeine
maybe but the I feel like the handling
of everyone with kid gloves and sort of
infantilizing of the workplace is in the
short-term the avoidance of pain but
guaranteed to create much larger
problems and much greater pain in the
long term so this approach I think is
just so refreshing and my question is
how do you when you are hiring people
and many of those hires I would imagine
are younger perhaps they've been they've
only known the environment where you
would go to HR and report they're not
they're not accustomed to having
uncomfortable conversations with
coworkers where they try to address
things directly do you do you try to in
any way coach them or provide them with
guidelines
for how to have those conversations oh
yes absolutely in fact actually Tim it's
interesting we hire a lot of people
straight out of college and that's great
it's so easy to tell them that and they
get it and they practice it it's people
who come to us from other companies that
need more coaching and and I think we
are able to do it by often having
difficult conversations at our
leadership meetings repeating that in
our team meetings repeating that again
and again given that we encourage people
to have difficult conversations we
encourage people to communicate when
they are not happy with something I
always prioritize that people know if
anybody text me or email says I have a
problem something has happened I want to
talk to you I I drop everything to
address it so people know there is
always a forum and including with me
where they can address problems and so I
think we've we've really created that
that atmosphere in that space here and
we also make it part of hiring so which
helps hire people who are more
comfortable having difficult
conversations you're your sister who I
love I believe has said that you're like
Athena I believe but on the flip side
I've also read that your favorite Greek
god is now I don't know if it's if you
would pronounce it Hermes or Hermes the
sky's right which confuses me as a Long
Island boy with no culture so all right
Hermes so why does she think that you're
like Athena and why is your favorite
Greek god Hermes well first of all you
know I wrote a book on Greek gods and
goddesses and where I approach them as
archetypes and and I believe that we all
carry all the gods and goddesses zena's
so the question is who is the most
dominant God so Athena is the goddess of
wisdom and I'm very flattered that my
sister thinks that's my dominant goddess
but I aspire to Hermes being my dominant
God because he's like my favorite God of
Greek mythology because he saw
multifaceted he's both tried like and
playful and wise he's mystical and
comfortable in the marketplace and he
represents everything I love about our
humanity in his very godlike way so he's
my favorite and I mean you you really
have have struck me in all of our
interactions and as I've observed you as
someone who's really made a conscious
effort as you said to be honest with
yourself and to see reality as it is but
there's there's one anecdote which I
think falls into this category it's kind
of related I think that I've never heard
from you so again I read a lot on the
internet and I have to be careful
sometimes with that but did you have a
conversation with Henry Kissinger about
your accent at one point and and and if
so can you please tell the story so you
know my I have been very conscious of my
accent for a long time and I am I did
try to change it in fact my ex-husband
gave me as a birthday gift which you may
consider very passive-aggressive
birthday gift a dialect coach for two
weeks to follow me around and give me
notes and it wasn't just any dialect
coach it was Jessica Drake who is a very
famous Hollywood dialect coach who
coached Forrest Gump
Society coach Tom Hanks in Forrest Gump
and anyway so she literally followed me
around at the time my children were
young she would put diphthong symbols on
dr. Seuss books or when I was reading to
my children I could practice and she
will put lifesavers on my tongue so I
would pronounce my long ease like long
ease and my short it's like short ease
and by the end of it I was paralyzed I
knew exactly what I was doing wrong but
I could not really be an authentic
functioning human being and speak proper
English so I gave up reluctantly the
hope of having speaking the Queen's
English and soon after I gave up my
husband though the two things and were
not related and then around that time I
was talking to Henry Kissinger
and I told him you know you're so
comfortable with your accent and I've
been sound comfortable with it and he
said Ariana give it up in American
public life you can never overestimate
the advantages of complete and total in
comprehensibility so you you learn to
embrace it
was it it was it easy I mean after that
conversation was it easy or what was the
yeah I think it was a combination of
seeing how I could never speak like
Jessica Drake wanted me to speak unless
I just kind of measured every word and
lost all spontaneity and also the fact
that Henry Kissinger is himself
completely comfortable with his heavy
German accent and now honestly I don't
think about it but for a long time it
really weighed on me
well you know I I wanted to hear you
tell that story which I really only knew
a tiny piece of it so I'm glad you told
the full story and because
I think you were very you live life very
proactively and it's been inspiring to
watch in our interactions and also as I
see you converse and interact and help
other people so I really encourage
people obviously to check out thrive
Global and I'll mention in in a second
where they can find you on various
social platforms but first and foremost
I just want to thank you for for taking
the time because this has been so fun
and I'm sure we only found the very tip
of the iceberg in terms of the stories
that you can tell so maybe we'll do a
round two sometime but I really
appreciate you making the time to have
the conversation our team I absolutely
loved it loved it and I would love to
invite your listeners to tell their own
stories you know their stories of burn
out their wake-up calls their life hacks
and we can post them on your site and on
thrive global and social them I really
believe that our stories can help others
in a way that goes beyond science and
data so I love collecting the stories
and I love inviting people to
participate well let's let's point them
to thrive global calm people should
check it out absolutely I'm going to
give you my email address and they can
email me directly that's how the
Huffington Post started remember okay so
before you do that Derek Siver's once
did that because he said no one's
listening after two and a half hours and
he had his inbox explode to the point
that it became very difficult to manage
is there a so I was the I'll leave it up
to you okay all right aah
at thrive global.com all right so all
right well you seem to be a masterful
surfer of technology so I will I will
leave you to contend with what comes out
of it but everybody heard it aah at
thrive global comm so you can send your
stories to Ariana and you can say hello
to her on LinkedIn Arianna Huffington
facebook also Arianna Huffington and
then Twitter and Instagram Arianna
Huffington comments that you'd like to
make before we finish up no that's my
ask let's share our stories and change
the culture so we can reduce all the
unnecessary suffering people are
experiencing thank you team so much for
all you are doing to make that possible
well thank you for sharing so much and
doing what you do and I'm absolutely
thrilled to have you on and for everyone
listening you can find links to
everything we've talked about in the
show notes as usual at tim dah blog
forward slash podcast Arianna thank you
so much and to everyone listening be
safe get your sleep and pay attention to
your body and how you feel and as always
thank you for listening hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and 500 Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
me undies I've spent the last few years
wearing underwear from these guys 24/7
or close to it outside of showers in
sexy time in swimming and they are the
most comfortable and colorful underwear
I've ever owned you should check out the
camouflage boxer briefs I'm a big fan me
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro Modell
what's that it is a fabric three times
softer than cotton trust me try it out
you'll understand why I wear these so
much
if underwear isn't your thing though I
would imagine everyone wears underwear
but if it isn't your thing munities also
makes socks their socks are spun from
premium material making them just as
comfortable as the underwear now right
now the undies has an exclusive offer
just for tim ferriss show listeners you
can get 20% off your first order in free
shipping so check it out take a look
some of them are pretty rad they have
different cereals from your childhood on
underwear and a lot more me undies calm
forward-slash Tim take a look me undies
comm /u Tim they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you're unhappy
with your purchase for any reason just
send it back and you receive a full
refund again that's me undies comm /tu
Tim for 20% off and free shipping this
episode is brought to you by freshbooks
man oh man do a lot of listeners of this
podcast and leaders of mine love fresh
books to the extent that I ended up
meeting with the CEO not very long ago
why are they so popular well they are
the number one the cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit cards and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier
and also in fact I recommend a PDF they
didn't ask me to read this part by the
way they put the other PDF a while back
called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour workweek with the
service business and the story in that
ebook its PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours and two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books comm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
[Applause]